die impfpflicht kommt nichts ja das war
das große versprechen der politik doch
jetzt schaut es ganz anders aus in
deutschland wird sie heftig diskutiert
und in österreich der sie schon fix und
soll bald umgesetzt werden und darüber
gesprochen hast du kein mit der
österreichischen verfassung ministerin
karoline edtstadler
und bei uns bei bild live österreichs
verfassungsministerien karoline
edtstadler schimpft und alfred stadler
einen schönen tag
wir erleben ja in dieser krise dass das
was in österreich kommt dann immer kurze
zeit später auch in deutschland kommt
die impfpflicht beschlossen in
österreich und wenig später auch
angekündigt in deutschland deswegen
nutzen wir sie ein bisschen als vorbild
sozusagen wissen sie schon genau wie sie
diese im pflicht durchsetzen wollen
haben sie schon einen klaren
österreichischen plan
wir sind jetzt gerade dabei die letzten
details abzusprechen was diesen
konkreten gesetzesvorschlag für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht was coop 19 in
österreich betrifft angela anbelangt wir
sind hier in den letzten gesprächen
jetzt wollen diese woche tatsächlich
auch in begutachtung gehen das heißt ja
wir haben hier schon relativ klar vor
augen wie das vonstatten gehen sollte
haben sie ein klares ziel wie viele
österreicher sie am ende zum impfen
bringen wollen also wie hoch soll die
impfquote dann schließlich seien nach
umsetzung der impfpflicht wir brauchen
hier und hier kann ich nur das
wiedergeben was expertinnen und experten
und auch sagen eine impfquote die in
richtung 90 prozent geben es wird immer
menschen geben die hier ausgenommen sein
müssen weil es kontraindikationen gibt
weil sie zb schwanger sind aber wir
wissen die impfung ist erprobt und sie
wirkt und sie ist der einzige weg raus
aus dieser pandemie ich stelle die frage
deshalb weil ja so spannend ist wie man
an die menschen ran kommt die sie bis
heute nicht haben impfen lassen womit
man die am ende überzeugt oder wenn man
sie auch nicht überzeugt zumindest zum
impfen bringen die die bei ihnen zb in
wiener auf der straße so heftig
protestieren auch teilweise gewalttätig
glauben sie dass sie die mit einer
impfpflicht zum impfen bringen
nein um ehrlich zu sein glaube ich das
nicht das sind großteils wirklich
menschen die fern stark verhaftet sind
in ihrer meinung in ihrer gegenmeinung
zu einer impfung die das auch lautstark
zum ausdruck bringen was und das möchte
ich das verfassungs ministerin auch
ausdrücklich betonen ja zulässig ist in
einer demokratie man muss nicht mit
allem einverstanden sein was die
regierung macht man hat die möglichkeit
seine meinung auch kundtun
aber gerade in einer situation wie wir
sie jetzt sehen ist es natürlich schon
höchst bedenklich wenn hier auch von
einer im parlament vertretenen partei
mit verschwörungs erzählungen hantiert
wird wenn hier angst geschürt wird und
wir schauen wahrscheinlich zu sehr auf
die die hier laut sind die hier auch
antisemitische parolen von sich geben
wir haben das wieder gesehen am
wochenende in wien wir müssen vielmehr
auf die schauen die zu hause sind junge
frauen die angst haben wenn es um ihren
kinderwunsch geht die wollen wir
erreichen und das sage ich auch ganz
deutlich die haben wir wahrscheinlich
bis jetzt noch nicht ausreichend
angesprochen ist das nicht bei einer
bankrotterklärung als politiker als
politikerin weil man am ende sehen muss
man hat es monatelang versucht mit
argumenten und hat es nicht geschafft
es ist wahrscheinlich das eingeständnis
dass wir nicht alle erreicht haben dass
es nicht ein selbstläufer ist selbst
dann wenn wir uns sehr gefreut haben in
der europäischen union insgesamt spreche
ich ja nicht nur für österreich dass wir
jetzt ausreichend impfstoff für alle
haben und es ist die notwendigkeit hier
politisch auch andere maßnahmen zu
setzen damit wir an die menschen ran
kommen und ja im rückblick soll ich
ihnen ganz deutlich ist es natürlich
immer leichter zu sagen das oder jenes
hätte man früher oder anders machen
können wir wollen den blick aber jetzt
nach vorne richten wir wollen jetzt ins
handeln kommen und wie gesagt nicht erst
ab anfang februar sondern schon heute
und morgen auch die menschen wirklich
versuchen zu erreichen und auch zu
überzeugen noch ganz kurz ein paar
fakten zur österreichischen pflicht wenn
sie denn dann tatsächlich so durchkommen
wird was für bußgelder drohen
nun das ist jetzt auch in der abstimmung
mit expertinnen und experten wir müssen
natürlich hier die abwägung vornehmen es
darf nicht zu hoch sein damit man hier
nicht noch größeren widerstand auslöst
es muss aber natürlich schon auch
spürbar sein aber was mir ganz wichtig
ist ungeachtet genauen höhe der
bußgelder der strafe die wir verhängen
ist dass wir die menschen in erster
linie zum impfen bringen wollen wir
wollen nicht dass die strafen zahlen wir
wollen nicht dass hier exekution
betrieben wird und diese strafen
hereingebracht werden sondern wir wollen
dass sie impfen und ich sage das auch
ganz bewusst dass verfassungsministerien
und auch ehemalige richterin das
verwaltungsverfahren ist er
normalerweise so ausgestaltet dass man
eine regel hat und wenn man dagegen
verstößt dann gibt es eben eine
geldbusse eine strafe in dem fall
überlegen wir uns auch wie wir sozusagen
auch dann den schon eine strafe verhängt
wird davon absehen können wenn die
menschen dann zur impfung gehen und sich
dazu entschließen danke herzlich für das
gespräch bei bild live österreich
verfassungsminister und europameisterin
carolin edtstadler vielen dank danke
ihnen auf wiedersehen und liebe grüße
aus wien